first of all I I want to thank you for
being here today I'm gonna be presenting
a collection of building blocks that I
have created over the years to do
consulting work using more from
technology what I do mostly is data
analysis systems and if I were to say
that the thing that maybe distinguishes
me the most the world from side of
things is that I use a lot of the GUI
functions to create applications okay so
that's what I'm going to be basically
emphasizing today okay so the world from
language is great right will love it
however I learned to save from marketing
check who is back there that shift-enter
is too much for many people okay
shift enter is like do you really want
for me to do that it's like too much so
many people out there would be willing
to use word from technology the benefits
of it when you know but asking them to
start coding is like too much for many
many people out there maybe not for any
one of us but for most people out there
is really a headache
however Wolfram language provide
provides beautiful functions and really
useful functions for creating gooeys and
they're not being used that that much I
would say and I do use them a lot and by
the way before I forget if you go if you
go to Mark's presentation at near 4:00
p.m. on data modeler some of the work
he's going to be presenting there which
is also based on GUI technology forward
from is performed by by me and we're
together anyhow so Steven mentioned
yesterday that Wolfram Alpha is there
for automating data analysis I mean he
didn't mean exactly that but the thing
is that doing things that way first of
all is way too expensive for most
companies okay
or the fortune companies no but for the
companies that support the fortune
companies it's too much
okay and there are thousands out there
that can honestly they cannot afford
Wolfram Alpha solutions not only that
Wolfram Alpha is like a general system
where you can do some analysis and by
the way I worked for two years as a
subcontractor with fall from solution so
and I happen to work with the technology
behind Wolfram Alpha so I understand a
little bit how it's done and the thing
is it's a sort of a general system that
if you really want to go deep and the
details you on the analysis you want to
do maybe work from alpha you could tell
it's not exactly what you want
anyhow so none of these ideas intends to
be like final proposition but it's like
just ideas right the idea is that I'm
going to be presenting presenting this
building blocks I've created and which
are mostly for data analysis working
with data I've been there like 14 years
as a consultant and many times I would
find that the quality of the data that
the customers have is really really poor
and right I see faces here so what's the
problem with that that you do a job and
at the end they're going to blame you
because they don't have quality
information okay so I decided to create
one of the main applications I have
developed so far which is a database
editor based on Mathematica and what is
that for we won't have time to show you
by the way there's nothing after this
presentation here so if you have time I
can be here for one hour after the
presentation showing you the
applications I've created we won't have
time to show you I won't have time to
show you everything I've done
not nearly close to the things I've done
so by the way--by presentation initially
it's going to be like slides okay and at
the end just to make sure that I say
everything I have to say at the end
we're going to be demonstrating
applications okay so this application
for data based technology is intended to
be used for different people at
different levels for example if you are
just a data entry the application is set
up for you to enter that are all day so
I have customers who are basically all
day typing data in this application that
you will see and why creating it because
with this tool I can improve a lot the
quality of data because I can set lots
of traps to make sure that the users
won't make me stupid mistakes okay for
example a common mistake when the data
is really poor is to find a character
where there will a letter where there
should be a number okay and if you use
simple data entry tools like a
spreadsheet that could happen and no one
will know and you've seen it so using
these tools that won't happen again so
data types are well classified and if
you try to save a a letter where there
is a number it will tell you now please
make sure that you feel that if you try
to sell a null record where it should be
filled no it's not gonna allow you to
make many of the common mistakes that
people do okay in in data entry so once
you have quality data many times you
don't have the depth in the analysis
that you need to make this issue seen in
your organization so what I do is I help
organizations to create or I do create
applications for organizations to help
them deep into their data to make
analysis okay and we will be able to
take a look at some of that and then if
something I mean I will create your
application to do analysis
what if you end up doing the same
analysis over and over they day after
day so maybe that could be converted
into a report you just click a button or
so and you get a report created for you
okay so the idea is to standardize data
analysis operation such that your data
has more value because lots of companies
have lots of data but at the time of
making a decision okay could you do the
analysis for me and then yes I'll do it
but it'll take me two days and then the
decision needs to be done this afternoon
so you know you don't have information
you have data but you don't have
information so the world from technology
is a good place to get started to solve
that problem okay the database editor
okay what I am gonna do here let's see
this is a screenshot sorry let me just
highlight a few things here this is a
screenshot of the database editor
showing that many data types can be
edited with this editor okay the first
one is text aerial okay it is telling
you it's a new value let me point with
this you can see so I hope you can see
here I type aerial and it's telling you
hey this value is new in the database it
had not been there before
and then I'm gonna I'm picking a
quantity here and then sales quantity I
can there say as soon as you start
typing if it's text or something like
that you know like a web browser it will
start showing you options so should you
make less mistakes and you're faster in
your data entry process I've also
created a date editor or date menu where
you can pick dates or days you're not
going to make mistakes it's always going
to be a formal date okay and you're
going to be able to see the calendar if
needed
okay to select the date and with a
single click you select a timestamp like
right away right now
right and so you can also edit graphics
graphics
the images images and images 3d binary
and even sound so many sort of data
types that you have in Mathematica you
can edit with it with this and create
real applications with it okay and time
flies okay so just to show you for
example here is a screenshot of a slide
where I am showing the database editor
used for image processing in this case I
am taking a shopper this company was
interested in analyzing shoppers so I
created a software for them that single
click the shopper you imported I say an
image single click it and then it breaks
into pieces and then you can save all
the pieces and start saving information
for doing further analysis for offering
client to clients and so forth so as you
can see we're up here is the database
editor okay
so it's a mathematical function that can
be used as a sub component of a bigger
GUI okay
it is a GUI by itself but can also be
used inside another GUI okay that's the
way it has been designed okay so here's
the GUI and here are some additional
items down there okay so I'm working
with this I mean I took the image I
broke it into parts and then here I'm
selecting this particular one which is
in yellow it's ready for you to take a
look at it and then it go with a click
goes into the database and then you feel
the other blanks and you save it okay so
there's somehow a manual process it's I
mean there are this is a very job I mean
to work with data many times you have to
do the process manually someone has to
be the slave there and not be that
well-paid but do that such an important
work anyhow the idea is that this is one
single application of the database
editor and then here is another
application this is for
another company and for example Here I
am I created a an application where you
for example here to type the the ID that
the employee that's that was responsible
for someone of actually processes okay
there's the day that sheave the machine
the part number and all of that
information at the bottom you have the
like a report of the latest records you
have been typing okay and then by the
way here you see a top view here right
it's abuse so here I am or the customer
in this case is capable of editing two
tables at the same time or n tables
ten tables so sometimes tables are
related so when you're doing data entry
you want to make sure that once you make
this entry here this part of it goes to
the next table and then you fill the
other part so that's all taken into
consideration here okay but well as I
said is to mush here's another
application Oh II radar overall
equipment effectiveness is a statistic
that is really important in
manufacturing facilities so in this case
what you see at the left is an instance
of the database editor where there are I
mean this is a real-time process at us a
machine is in this case packaging things
you would see shifts in the process of
what you see there like green yellow
orange and so forth are different states
of a machine that is continuously
packing packing products and and some of
that information goes again into the
database editor so in this case a the
database editor is being fed by a
manufacturing process in real time by
the help of a human being it's not
perfectly I mean this is for human
intervention all of them anyhow Wow
let's see best viewpoints well it's an
old application I created for doing data
analysis a beautiful application you can
do many many things with it and just as
an example here when you upload the data
set you can be
from a menu wishes the field that you're
going to analyze and we chart the fields
that you are going to be grouping by
okay and then in this case for example
we made analysis of a particular
variable that was sales and you pick the
group by variables and you can select
which of the item categories from each
of the group by variables are selected
or kept in the analysis and at the end
you have this hierarchical analysis like
okay so these are the sales say by
country by department by product top
five for each of them something like
that's really nice works really nice so
however I need help from Wolfram to sell
it more anyhow the idea is that once you
use it at some point if you say hey this
is the analysis that we need for this
company so there's a way to capture the
state of the application and and have
like a script that you can feed in every
single day get the same analysis turn
with that script so that will help you
to define the analysis that eventually
will be automated in some other
processes okay okay so this is a data
analysis application so this is a block
number two block number one was the
database editor this is block number two
and checking time here this may look
simple but it is not this or pallets for
our clients now why these pallets are
special well first of all it's important
to provide a pallet to the customer so I
said I mean open the pallet just click
on the button and then get your
application ready that's important now
why these pallets are a bit different
because mostly because of the two
options down there at the bottom of each
of them you have two options and the one
at the left is stupid but it's important
is the background color of the
application so I used to have a single
background and some people hated
some people loved it so now you can
before you open the application you can
tell what the background is going to
look like and then you work it it's
gonna be great it's great it's gonna be
something else you pick it so great
background not that important but still
it's important to keep the client happy
right otherwise they're gonna kill you
second check for updates that's the most
important one particularly because of
the way it's implemented I mean you all
you all know that we work hitting and
chasing box all the time right so when
the client discovers a blog and the
application is implemented in 20
machines what do you do okay are you
going to one at a time I mean they're
going to hate you so what I've done is
that with that check for updates since I
always work with data in databases the
files the update files are sent to a
database with the update you go to the
database you bring the files everything
gets updated like this okay I from my
home I bring in the new bids from their
desk every one with a single click they
they get their application updated
that's really important to get things
working in real life okay so once those
three builds I mean these are the main
building blocks I use for creating
applications once those three building
blocks are ready I start creating what I
call a radar system which is reliable
and accurate data analysis and reporting
system okay so it's gonna be an
application where you just get in there
with a few clicks you get your analysis
done okay and these applications are
usually used at different levels in the
organization you will see I mean let me
say it this way
so let me go through a better screenshot
here
well more or less okay with this
application I tried to hide everything I
could so you will see some things that
like don't belong to the application and
I do have permission to show this from
the customer with this application you
will see that there are different tabs
so depending on your interest or your
level at the organization you will pick
the tab that is better for you okay
so with this application when you get in
there what do you see there
okay it's a summary of the current year
of a production plant for different
products and once you get in there you
click on the radar bottom at the left
top corner here and that report is
generated instantly okay not instantly
it takes a couple of seconds could take
30 seconds or so because it's lots of
analysis down there but anyhow the idea
is that once you get in there a single
click will give you lots of information
you didn't know
so the general manager of this company
loves me he wants to marry me
no he's really really happy with this
work because he he was he would tell me
I was blind I couldn't see anything and
now I see what's going on in my
facilities in so for example from here
you can select are this tire the time
span where you want your analysis
perform and whether you want to do your
analysis and the monthly basis weekly
basis daily basis the sort of analysis
you want to generate the clients you
want to take a look at maybe you want
only some of them or some of the
products only and then there are these
are the basic options so there are
advanced options like for you know
simple things to make the plot look
better and for example here the products
are hearing on purpose you can were here
is a control for making this plot no
longer so everything is going to be seen
but I on purpose
wanted to hide all the products for this
presentation but there are all the
products on the right so you can click
on any of them at the right there
those are buttons
this here at the right our button so you
can click on any of them and you will
get a report a more detailed report for
each of those products okay so maybe
none of you works at manufacturing but
the idea is you you you can I wanted to
show you some ideas of what you can do
with the Wolfram technology in terms of
graphical user interfaces you have data
I mean shift-enter and then next page
and another sale is too much sometimes
right working with something like this
is way more simpler and many people are
going to be able to adapt the technology
in the organization and just use it
right and buy more so Stephen was asking
for help I want to help if I'm sure
there are work on people here I want to
help but I need your help I need to work
together to make this available to
people I think that maybe I think that
there's a huge space that were from is
not taking advantage of something like
this ok I'm a one-man show
with a I have one guy who is helping me
and my wife supports me and I've done
lots of things one-man show I'm sure
that there are many many many things
that we can do I live in Puerto Rico I
mean you know after the here again
there's nothing but trees on the floor
so still and making money so there's
great opportunity saying big economies I
hope that I I could get some attention
anyhow so the main idea I wanted to
bring and after I finished this I'm
going to do some demonstrations ok if
you have time but the main idea I wanted
to bring is I'm ready to help you
creating applications with the world
from language they are great they're
really useful they can be really
beautiful but if you're not ready for
that I can help you also get ready for
that by training on your organization on
how to create gooeys I personally
participated on the world from trainings
but I think that none of them
is that let's say that I can compliment
war from trainings going deeper into
data analysis and graphical user
interface generation anyhow so this is a
formal presentation now I'm going to
before I close I'm going to make some
demonstrations are there any questions
no means no okay
thank you thank you thank you yeah yeah
III think that yeah yeah I think that
there's lots of phase two
I mean to do other things with the world
from technology okay so any other
comments or questions
well dad well first of all I don't have
a broad view because I'm not I mean I
can only address small and medium
companies so I cannot see exactly what's
going on the higher levels however for
you type for example Crystal Reports is
one of the applications they use I mean
it is far away from the things I do
honestly honestly I do and I can tell
because of the reaction of my clients
are really happy however Crystal Reports
just to mention one they sell really
really well I mean they do selling
really well so and by the way they let
me tell you this example I created one
of a system that I and the one that I
showed just showed I created to this
client after he decided to quit on a two
hundred thousand project on a software
that they bought that they realized was
not going to help them okay so I mean
honestly I don't know well the
competition but I know well that what I
am presenting here is great for almost
any organization that manages data that
nowadays is every single organization
has that okay so let's take a look at so
this is an application this that is
about to be ROI no it's about this it's
about to be delivered I'm working on it
almost as I as I speak most probably in
this month this is a pallet for them
this is a laboratory that takes care of
primates in the University of Puerto
Rico
and I've created data entry applications
for them and also a radar application
for them to do analysis okay so let me
allow you to participate I can show you
the database editor or a radar
application who votes radar okay great
okay thank you the other Raider was is
more powerful I would say but anyhow the
idea is the same and this one
well let me say by the way this is like
a local test as you can see in the
palette this is running on my computer
this is not this is all data so it's not
actual eyes anyhow I wanted to say that
in some instances I do something like
what you see here i pre compute many
things for the GUI for a parade really
fast ok if I don't do this the GUI is
going to be really slow so the first
part of the GUI I'm telling the user hey
this is going to be performed only once
please give me a second okay and now
things are pre computed for you for the
application such that things run much
faster okay and still that may come up
again so here in this application you
can select from standard reports there
are some reports here and there are
other reports so you depending on which
type of trip with the power and sort of
people you select and there are some
child reports and just to mention this
the first one you have here let me pick
one animal which happens to have
meaningful information that's zero zero
five me so zero zero here as you can see
this is how it works you start typing it
starts suggesting you hey do you really
want so you should not make mistakes and
by the way you are not going to be able
to select an animal that doesn't exist
okay so that's the animal you wanna
analyze and the radar you always have to
go to radar to to tell the application
I'm done okay so you were done and here
is the simple report okay this or this
is some information about that animal
this is the animal the sex species and
so forth
here is some viral the gene for me this
is like a report right there are some
weights okay so this is a history of
weight for that animal in time and at
the end you have like a confidence
interval whether the animal is doing
well or not and by the way it seems to
be a little bit skinny so here is a
record of the Vasanth bus passings
for that animal and okay and
reproduction no offspring recorded for
that animal and so forth so but this is
really really a basic I mean this were
the characteristic for the animal and I
think that well if you go to to the
pathology information for that animal
then you get other information please
note that this is a system that is about
to get started so I don't have much
meaningful information here but you see
the scheme right how it works so so here
you have some clinical information
history biology history I don't have
much microscopic finding and I wanted to
show you this okay the system saves
images and these are images taken from
the world from language I guess these
are not real images but the thing is you
can I could if you are interested after
I finished because I think I should be
finishing now yeah I should be finishing
but if you have time I can show you how
to type in images on how to you know how
to use the editor to to save images in
the database along with the description
like the date or whatever comes along
with it so and just to finish if you
select what let's see
reproduction reports let's see honestly
I don't know what's gonna happen okay
this one is also evaluated only once per
session is doing some pre computations
so the idea is you select from this menu
what sort of what does this mean how
many animals
this is reproduction so this is a female
has had no there are 21 let's see I'm
lost here my report
oh they this is the corral I don't know
how to pronounce that in English well
the animals are located in the corral
and so and this is this animal has had
one offspring and so forth so all of
them have only one and you know that's
the idea and you can see the data behind
this plot I guess the production okay so
that's it I'm done so usually I cannot
get done there are so many things one of
them is that you can export PDFs or XLS
files if you have data that you want to
export somewhere you can do that or
whenever you do some X let's take a look
let's let's see if this can export our
same excel file XLS and hopefully there
are no Box this is a huge application
open the exported file I'm gonna say yes
and here is the exported data so so I
mean what from is too much for many
people so you have to be able to take
the data away bring it in and take it
out so that's my basic presentation I
can share more we have space I'd think
that no one is gonna use this meeting
this room now so I can show more things
but if you have any questions or any
comments I do have business cards
somewhere around here so if you're
interested please let me know thank you